with work from home being the norm in
today's era people spend considerable
amount of time on the internet often
without specific measures to ensure a
secure session
apart from individuals organizations
worldwide that host data and conduct
business over the internet are always at
the risk of a ddos attack
these ddos attacks are getting more
extreme with hackers getting easy access
to botnet farms and compromised devices
as can be seen in the graph three of the
six strongest ddos attacks were launched
in 2021 with the most extreme attack
occurring just last year in 2020
lately cyber criminals have been
actively seeking out new services and
protocols for amplifying these ddos
attacks
active involvement with hacked machines
and botnets allow further penetration
into the consumer space allowing much
more elaborate attack campaigns
apart from general users multinational
corporations have also had their fair
share of problems
github a platform for software
developers was the target of a ddos
attack in 2018.
widely suspected to be conducted by
chinese authorities this attack went on
for about 20 minutes after which the
systems were brought into a stable
condition
it was the strongest ddos attack to date
at the time and made a lot of companies
reconsider the security practices to
compare such attacks
even after years of experimentation ddos
attacks are still at large and can
affect anyone in the consumer and
corporate space
hey everyone this is bev from simply
learn and welcome to this video on what
is a ddos attack
let's take a look at the topics we will
be covering today
we start by learning what is a ddos
attack and how it works on a face by
phase level
we learn about the distinct categories
in ddos attacks and the potential aim of
hackers when they launch a ddos attack
campaign
we also look at some preventive measures
that can be taken to protect oneself
from these ddos attacks
finally we have a demonstration of how
such attacks can hamper the working of a
server system using vmware and parrot
security operating system
but before moving forward make sure you
are subscribed to the simply learn
youtube channel don't forget to hit the
bell icon to receive updates about more
informative videos from our channel so
let's learn more about what is a ddos
attack
a distributed denial of service attack
or ddos is when an attacker or attackers
attempt to make it impossible for a
service to be delivered
this can be achieved by thwarting access
to virtually anything servers devices
services networks applications and even
specific transactions within
applications
in a dos attack it's one system that is
sending the malicious data or requests a
ddos attack comes from multiple systems
generally these attacks work by drowning
a system with requests for data
this could be sending a web server so
many requests to serve a page that it
crashes under the demand or it could be
a database being hit with a higher
volume of queries
the result is available internet
bandwidth cpu and ram capacity become
overwhelmed
the impact could range from a minor
annoyance from disrupted services to
experiencing entire websites
applications or even entire businesses
taking offline
more often than not these attacks are
launched using machines in a botnet
a botnet is a network of devices that
can be triggered to send requests from a
remote source often known as the command
and control center
the bots in the network attack a
particular target thereby hiding the
original perpetrator of the ddos
campaign
but how do these devices come under the
botnet and what are the requests being
made to the web servers
let's learn more about these and how dos
attack work
a ddos attack is a two-phase process
in the first phase a hacker creates a
botnet of devices
simply put a vast network of computers
are hacked via malware ransomware or
just simple social engineering
these devices become a part of the
botnet which can be triggered anytime to
start bombarding a system or a server on
the instruction of the hacker that
created the botnet
the devices in this networks are called
bots or zombies
in the second phase a particular target
is selected for the attack
when the hacker finds the right time to
attack all the zombies in the botnet
network send these requests to the
target thereby taking up all the servers
available bandwidth
these can be simple ping requests or
complex attacks like syn flooding and
udp flooding
the aim is to overwhelm them with more
traffic than the server or the network
can accommodate the goal is to render
the website or service inoperable
there is a lot of wiggle room when it
comes to the type of ddos attack a
hacker can go with
depending on the target's vulnerability
we can choose one of the three broad
categories of ddos attacks
volume based attacks use massive amounts
of bogus traffic to overwhelm a resource
it can be a website or a server
they include icmp udap and spoofed
packet flood attacks
the size of volume based attack is
measured in bits per second
these attacks focus on clogging all the
available bandwidth for the server
thereby cutting the supply shot
several requests are sent to the server
all of which warrant a reply thereby not
allowing the target to cater to the
general legitimate users
next we have the protocol level attacks
these attacks are meant to consume
essential resources of the target server
they exhaust the load balancers and
firewalls which are meant to protect the
system against the ddos attacks
these protocol attacks include syn
floods and smurf ddos among others and
the size is measured in packets per
second
for example in ssl handshake server
replies to the hello message sent by the
hacker which will be the client in this
case but since the ip is proved and
leads nowhere the server gets stuck in
an endless loop of sending the
acknowledgement without any end in sight
finally we have the application level
attacks
application layer attacks are conducted
by flooding applications with
maliciously crafted requests
the size of application layer attacks is
measured in request per second
these are relatively sophisticated
attacks that target the application and
operating system level vulnerabilities
they prevent the specific applications
from delivering necessary information to
users and hawk the network bandwidth up
to the point of a system crash
examples of such an attack are http
flooding and bgp hijacking
a single device can request data from a
server using http post or get without
any issues
however when the requisite botnet is
instructed to bombard the server with
thousands of requests the database
bandwidth gets jammed and it eventually
becomes unresponsive and unusable
but what about the reasons for such an
attack there are multiple lines of
thought as to why a hacker decides to
launch a ddos attack on unsuspecting
targets
let's take a look at a few of them
the first option is to gain a
competitive advantage
many ddos attacks are conducted by
hacking communities against rival groups
some organizations hire such communities
to stagger their rivals resources at a
network level to gain an advantage in
the playing field
since being a victim of a ddos attack
indicates a lack of security the
reputation of such a company takes a
significant hit allowing the rivals to
cover up some ground
secondly some hackers launch these ddos
attacks to hold multinational
corporations at ransom
the resources are jammed and the only
way to clear the way is if the target
company agrees to pay a designated
amount of money to the hackers
even a few minutes of inactivity is
detrimental to a company's reputation in
the global market and it can cause a
spiral effect both in terms of market
value and product security index
most of the time a compromise is reached
and the resources are freed after a
while
tdos attacks have also found use in the
political segment
certain activists tend to use ddos
attacks to voice their opinion
spreading the word online is much faster
than any local rally or forum
primarily political these attacks also
focus on online communities ethical
dilemmas or even protests against
corporations
let's take a look at a few ways that
companies and individuals can protect
themselves against edos attacks
the company can employ load balancers
and firewalls to help protect the data
from such attacks
load balancers reroute the traffic from
one server to another in a ddos attack
this reduces the single point of failure
and adds resiliency to the server data
a firewall blocks unwanted traffic into
a system and manages the number of
requests made at a definite rate it
checks for multiple attacks from a
single ip and occasional slowdowns to
detect a ddos attack in action
early detection of a ddos attack goes a
long way in recovering the data lost in
such an event
once you've detected the attack you will
have to find a way to respond for
example you will have to work on
dropping the malicious jdos traffic
before it reaches your server so that it
doesn't throttle and exhaust your
bandwidth
here's where you will filter the traffic
so that only legitimate traffic reaches
the server by intelligent routing you
can break the remaining traffic into
manageable chunks that can be handled by
your cluster resources
the most important stage in ddos
mitigation is where you will look for
patterns of redos attacks and use those
to analyze and strengthen your
mitigation techniques for example
blocking an ip that's repeatedly found
to be offending is a first step
cloud providers like amazon web services
and microsoft azure who offer high
levels of cyber security including
firewalls and threat monitoring software
can help protect your assets and network
from ddos criminals
the cloud also has greater bandwidth
than most private networks so it is
likely to fail if under the pressure of
increased tdos attacks
additionally reputable cloud providers
offer network redundancy duplicating
copies of your data systems and
equipment so that if your service
becomes corrupted or unavailable due to
a ddos attack you can switch to a secure
access on backed up versions without
missing a beat
one can also increase the amount of
bandwidth available to a host server
being targeted
since ddos attacks fundamentally operate
on the principle of overwhelming systems
with heavy traffic
simply provisioning extra bandwidth to
handle unexpected traffic spikes can
provide a measure of protection
this solution can prove expensive as a
lot of that bandwidth is going to go
unused most of the time
a content delivery network or a cdn
distributes your content and boosts
performance by minimizing the distance
between your resources and end users it
stores the cached version of your
content in multiple locations and this
eventually mitigates ddos attacks by
avoiding a single point of failure when
the attacker is trying to focus on a
single target
popular cdns include akamai cdn
cloudflare aws cloudfront etc
let's start with our demo regarding the
effects of ddos attacks on a system
for a demo we have a single device that
will attack a target making it a dos
attack of sorts
once a botnet is ready multiple devices
can do the same and eventually emulate a
ddos attack
to do so we will use the virtualization
software called vmware with an instance
of parrot security operating system
running for a target machine we will be
running another vmware instance of a
standard linux distribution known as
linux light
in a target device we can use wireshark
to determine when the attack begins and
see the effects of the attack
accordingly
this is linux like which is a target
machine and this is parrot security
which is used by the hacker when trying
to launch a ddos attack this is just one
of the distros that can be used
to launch the attack we must first find
the ip address of our target
so to find the ip address we open the
terminal
we use the command ifconfig
and here we can find the ip address
now remember we're launching this attack
in vmware now the both the instances of
parrot security and linux light are
being run on my local network so the
address that you can see here is
192.168.72.129
which is a private address
this ip cannot be accessed from outside
the network basically anyone who is not
connected to my wifi
when launching attacks with public
servers or public addresses
it will have a public ip address that
does not belong to the 192168 subnet
once we have the ip address
we can use a tool called
hping3
hping3 is an open source packet
generator and analyzer for the tcp ip
protocol
to check what are the effects of an
attack we will be using wireshark
wireshark is a network traffic analyzer
we can see whatever traffic that is
passing through the linux light distro
is being displayed over here with the ip
address the source ip and the
destination ip as to where the request
is being transferred to
once we have the dos attack launched you
can see the results coming over here
from the source ip which will be parrot
security now to launch the hping3
command we need to give sudo access to
the console which is the root access
now we have the root access for the
console
the hping3 command will have a few
arguments to go with it which are as you
can see on the screen
minus s
and a flood
a hyphen v
hyphen p80 and
the ip address of the target which is
168 72.129
in this command we have a few arguments
such as the minus s which specifies syn
packets
like in an ssl handshake we have the syn
request that the client sends to the
server to initiate a connection
the hyphen flood aims to ignore the
replies that the server will send back
to the client in response to the syn
packets here the parent security os is
the client and linux slide being the
server
minus v stands for verbosity as in where
we will see some output when the
requests are being sent
the hyphen p80 stands for port 80 which
we can replace the port number if we
want to attack a different port
and finally we have the ip address of
our target
as of right now if we check wireshark it
is relatively clear and there is no
indication of a ddos attack incoming
now once we launch the attack over here
we can see the requests coming in from
this ip which is 192 168 72.128
till now even the network is responsive
and so is linux lite
the requests keep on coming and we can
see the http
flooding has started in flood mode
after a few seconds of this attack
continuing the server will start
shutting down
now remember linux light is a distro
that can focus on one that serves as a
back end
now remember linux light is a distro and
such linux distros are served as backend
to many servers across the world for
example a few seconds have passed from
the attack
now the system has become completely
irresponsive
this has happened due to the huge number
of requests that came from pirate
security
you can see whatever i press nothing is
responded even the wireshark has stopped
capturing new request because the cpu
usage right now is completely 100
and at this point of time anyone who is
trying to request some information from
this linux distro or where this linux
distro is being used as a backend for a
server or a database cannot access
anything else the system has completely
stopped responding and any request any
legitimate request from legitimate users
will be dropped
once you stop the attack over here it
takes a bit of time to settle down
now remember it's still out of control
but eventually the traffic dies down and
the system regains its strength
it is relatively easy to gauge right now
the effect of a dos attack now remember
this linux light is just a vm instance
actual website servers and
web databases they have much more
bandwidth and are very secure and it's
tough to break into
that is why we cannot use a single
machine to break into them
that is where a ddos attack comes into
play what we did right now is a dos
attack as in a single system is being
used to penetrate a
target server using a single request now
when a ddos attack multiple systems such
as multiple parallel security instances
or multiple zombies or bots in a botnet
network can attack a target server to
completely shut down the machine and
drop any legitimate request thereby
rendering the service and the target
completely unusable and
inoperable
as a final note we would like to remind
that this is for educational purposes
only and we do not endorse any attacks
on any one domains only test this on
servers and networks that you have
permission to test on
hope you learned something interesting
today if you have any questions
regarding the lesson feel free to ask us
in the comments section and we will get
back to you as soon as possible
thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here